freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video es ist mal wieder soweit ein
tag essen wie in einem der
lieblingsserie auf meinem kanal und
heute habe ich wieder ein land
ausgesucht welches auf den ersten blick
sehr vertraut scheint aber ich bin mir
sicher werden im laufe des tages einige
überraschungen erleben wir essen heute
einen tag wie in österreich und die
erste überraschung gibt es vielleicht
schon beim frühstück weil wenn man so
darüber nachdenkt die ist man eigentlich
in österreich zum frühstück also sie
erst unsere nachbarn eigentlich zum
frühstück und die antwort lautet gar
nicht so anders als wir das hier habe
ich mal vorbereitet dass es einen teller
mit zwei das sind heute keine brötchen
auch wenn ich sie in deutschland gekauft
hat mit zwei semmeln dazu gibt es die
rola washington drei verschiedene sorten
österreichischer käse dazu noch ein
bisschen butter marmelade und honig also
im großen und ganzen gar nichts
großartig anderes aber wenn ich das
ganze mit meiner persönlichen ernährung
vergleiche ist es doch relativ anders
weil das würde ich sagen sie ehrlich
will ich mir nicht unbedingt zum
frühstück holen also ich sehe ja auch
davon ich mag ja sehr gerne die große
vielfalt die unsere welt kulinarisch zu
bieten hat und irgendwie ist das so ein
bisschen eine sache die ich mir
zumindest länger nicht gemacht habe
deshalb bin ich umso gespannter ob ich
mich heute damit anfreunden kann die
kaminwurzen lasse ich aber gerne für
eric dass hier sind nass oder richtigen
semmel aus oder so ein schönes rundes
brötchen hat ja auch nicht gedacht dass
mir mal vor laufender kamera ein
brötchen schmieren ich meine ich werde
nicht ewig viel dazu sagen können das
gehört dazu also es gibt zum beispiel so
ein tiroler größte gibt es auch das ist
gekochte kartoffeln noch mal so durch
geschwenkt in der gusseisernen pfanne
mit speck und spiegelt aber der
gesamtheit von österreich ist das laufen
ein recherchen das authentische
frühstück deshalb aus mich dafür ziehen
bevor ich mir hier eine semmel reihen
fahre will ich sagen rufen wir mal
jemanden an der sich sehr gut mit dem
österreichischen essen und generell mit
essen auskennt in lieben lukas zeigt er
wird mich sowieso demnächst mal in köln
besuchen
[Musik]
hallo mini um jedes mal etwas anderes
geht du sagst was sind deine go2
traditionellen sachen wenn man einen tag
wie in österreich essen will
okay das ist schon so eine idee aber ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob jetzt mehr
rechte mein
okay damit kann ich arbeiten wäre es gut
ja was ist so das traditionelle
österreichische frühstück ich habe jetzt
nicht in wien sondern in österreich habe
ich gesehen dass es so wertet er nicht
zum deutschen ist mehr somit so sammeln
und so
ok dann habe ich gut schon mal
recherchiert das ist schon mal gut
wie bei so weiter wie nav ist sondern du
willst
du kannst du denn
du bist in meinem kopf ist sowas von
österreich hat jeder mit dem ich vor
jahren seien sie ja der nook ärzte aus
österreich der macht sie auch die videos
und so aber das ist ja lustig das ist
ein klischee mit dem hoffentlich schon
mal aufräumen kann vermeiden teilt aber
das hätte ich musste es glücklich ich
dachte du seist aus österreich ich bin
nicht mehr ich freue mich auf meinen
besuch nicht auch schon ein bisschen an
gibt diese
starter das hätte ich wirklich nicht
gedacht ich packen wir jetzt hier mal
ein südtiroler schinken auf meine semmel
dass der lukas ja auch gesagt und
frühstücke erstmal in ruhe muss ich dazu
jetzt viel sagen ich weiß es ja nicht
[Musik]
nutzt ja fast geschafft normalerweise
bisher schon mal einen wissen sein muss
sagen den reis früchte mehr so
klassisches sonntagsfrühstück 1 so war
brötchen holen lässt sich gut gehen
erkennen lassen dass das nichts
besonderes aber trotzdem sehr sehr
lecker kann mir nur ein bisschen käse
übrig damit muss ich mir noch was
einfallen lassen aber vor allem habe ich
muss doch was schönes leckeres warmes
dafür will ich sagen gehen wir zum
mittagessen mal zu einem
österreichischen restaurants und
erkenntnis vielleicht freunde zeit fürs
mittagessen und ihr könnt euch
vielleicht schon denken die leute die
den kanal aufmerksam verfolgen wissen wo
wir hingehen müssen wir sind hier vom
restaurant group as und ihr seht schon
in österreich flaggen ist nämlich ein
rein österreichisches restaurant deshalb
muss es einfach heute im video
stattfinden und wir sind immer sehr sehr
gerne hier werden dass 100 euro
überraschungsmenü auf ihr also es auch
ein grobes raster zum mittagstisch das
glaube ich eine gute station deshalb was
uns rein schauen dass uns gucken was für
ein österreichisches reingehen können
sind wir wieder da sind
ja also ich muss eigentlich ganz großen
die karte schauen so dass gute es wäre
mir die möglichkeit verschiedene
traditionelle österreichische speisen
auszutesten und deshalb wären wir das
auch tun also es ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt üblich dass man talent zum
mittagessen ist in österreich aber wir
werden das tun wir werden backhendl
geschehen und dann kann man auch einen
keller tafelspitz und wieder spitze
bestellt das muss
ich bin ja auch waffe das ist schon ein
schönes schickes restaurant und das aber
ganz traditionell ein bisschen nahrung
will sagen backhendl
wo
siehst du unfassbar saftig schön
knusprig sortiert und wirklich hacken
vergleicht und was man denken will man
würde jetzt eigentlich mit diesem
schicken aber schmeckt so viel
intensiver
das auch so ein ding auch dass du gar
nicht klar ist für mich sieht das aus
wie so ein perfekter schicken wir haben
dieses mal am knochen so hose und
zugleich aber als schicken
so intensiv
salzig kite du musst erst mal so
schlucken aber nur fleischsaft das ist
so sagt ja und ich denke dass mainz mit
diesem so dass es mehr als einfach nur
ein fundiertes stück schicken jetzt noch
mal so eine andere tiefe von geschmack
eher als würde auch einem sehr leicht
gemacht dass sie zu halten man merkt
schon das backhendl das anders ist als
fried chicken es ist nicht so als wenn
man keine österreichische
zubereitungsart von haben sonst ist das
eigene system eigengeschmack und auch
einen sehr sehr guten geschmack an der
sich auch lohnt also man braucht nicht
immer noch
am meisten gespannt bin ich dabei auch
den tafelspitz gleichen wenn man bei
kaya oberstaufen zu kommen also so kann
es weitergehen das wird noch
gefrühstückt so hat man auf jeden fall
noch lust und platz für mehr
[Musik]
dann starten wir mal daten hoch und wir
müssen mit dem wiener schnitzel
schreiben wirklich es ist von klein auf
bange so ein gericht das kann ich immer
ist das liebe ich ein paar und wenn es
richtig richtig gut gemacht ist dann es
heute besonders dann könnte ich mir mal
ein bisschen von der preise der
marmelade beziehungsweise man sagt hier
irgendwie anders dazu das wurde aber
unsere schnitzel video kritisiert dass
marmelade gesagt auch den innen drin
heiße wären dran und
er macht ja nix ne durch alleinverdiener
spitze ist die österreichische küche
erzählen oder allein für das wiener
schnitzel glaube hier muss weiter auf
ein paar verschwitzte und zu klein das
sind die wiener wiener einlagen ganz
genau stimmten mit den tafeln spitzen
klein bisschen durch auch ein sehr edles
stück tafelspitz ja auch
interessanterweise in den
verschiedensten ländern ganz verschieden
zubereitet es kann ja auch ein grill
oder so und hier als dass er in
südamerika war hier bei uns und
deutschsprachigen raum seit 28 da wird
das eigentlich nur als suppe verarbeitet
gehabt aber man versteht auch warum die
suppe ist so richtig schön kräftig mein
papa zum beispiel beliebt kräftiges auf
der seite mal so es gibt nichts was für
mich vieles auch ein bisschen weil das
ist sowas einfach es irgendwie also
wirklich auch sehr lecker auch hier habe
er selbst hart und es macht wirklich
alles cultra viel spaß zu essen und
jetzt probiere ich hier drüben mal in
frittierten tafelspitz mit ein bisschen
davon missioniert von
es ist ich meine es mit eigenen augen
ein königliches mittagessen es ist so
lecker ich fertig ist das schnitzel und
alles drumherum und ich bin mir sicher
ich werde es lief also ich habe vor
lauter schnitzel kann ich den erdapfel
gurken salat gegessen aber der ist
natürlich ohne es probiert zu haben
krank auch so eine sache nicht befragen
wollte beziehungsweise auch flächen
community wir waren uns ja in der suche
des nächsten landes österreich etwas
uneinig seien dabei die entscheidung ist
so was nimmt man also es gibt ja
unendlich viel etappen so wohin will man
unter dem heutigen video finden sich
drei länder in den kommentaren und ihr
könnt mit eurem like entscheiden welches
land wir als nächstes kulinarisch
bereisen werden also machen exoten ich
mache so etwas naheliegendes und bin
gespannt was sie sagt dann könnt ihr
einfach licon und dann noch der
kommentar mit den meisten texte dann in
der nächsten folge statt
auch challenge dann so sich in dieses
land zu hineinzuversetzen bei bisher
haben wir immer das genommen worauf wie
am meisten
genießen das ganze noch vier leute sind
uns gleich noch mal kurz wieder und dann
zum abendessen ins nämlich selbst in die
küche geht weil er den kochlöffel
schwingen und wird einem
österreichischen klassiker zaun also
leute es war wirklich ein absoluter
traum hat noch eine kleine süßigkeit
hinterher bekommen und ich muss euch
sagen dass sowas ist für österreichische
küche meine adresse in köln ich glaube
aber auch die adresse in köln weil es
gibt nicht so viel auswahl an dass auf
dem niveau feierabend jetzt muss ich
probieren daran anzuknüpfen beim versuch
selbst käsespätzle zu machen los geht's
so kommen wir mal an essen es ist ein
hübsches setting was wir hier haben wir
haben verschiedene krisen 50 stück
wiedererkennt wir haben zwei ein
bisschen mit ein bisschen wasser märz
weiß dass ich jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben 32 alte machen käsespätzle ja
ein österreichischer klassiker hütten
essen freue mich sie zu machen denn ich
habe so eine extra google das hat mir
meine mama geschenkt das ist eine
spätzle spätzle schaben also ich weiß
nicht genau auf jeden fall kann man es
machen anscheinend richtig gut selbst
machen das möchte ich probiert ich fange
aber an indem wir selbst unsere
röstzwiebeln herstellen
wir haben bärbel felsen käse und
steinsalz käse allesamt aus österreich
liegen können aber alle möglichen seien
die werde ich jetzt einmal reiben und
dann haben wir einige schon vorbereitet
und machen aus sondern dehnt also der
käse ist gerieben jetzt jetzt an den
teig und vertrauten wenn ich sage jetzt
geht es richtig schmeckt er mir 200
gramm mehl als normal des haushalts mehl
dazugeben wird es weiter selbst auch
richtig man kann sich das nicht mehr
möglich ist kommt er wie man sagen
aufträge pro person 100 gramm mehl 1 1
50 milliliter wasser mit riesensatz also
kann man sich auf jeden fall mit merken
eier und mehr verbinde ich erst mal ein
bisschen ruhe und sobald das mehl nicht
mehr richtig gut aufgenommen wird geben
wir ein bisschen wasser hinzu und jetzt
eigentlich schon auf das wasser dazu und
durchschnitt bis man die gewünschte
konsistenz hat ne ganz genau der teil
also relativ flüssig werden also
dickflüssiger als beispielsweise ein
cache teig nicht so glatt wie jetzt so
eingeschränkt da kommt schon langsam
dahin da sich gut auf das ging wirklich
in nullkommanix hatten wir schon mal
unseren spätzle auf den topf passt wie
angegossen und ich mache einen topf mit
wasser voll zum abschrecken
uns ist es sehr sehr gut und ab geht die
post
wird schon wenn ihr so von der seite
guckt wieder unten so die einzelnen
spätzle rausfallen funktioniert
perfektioniert richtig gut irgendwie ein
fleckerl selbstgemachtes selbst
gestalten schwätze krieg auch solange es
viel arbeit das ist unsere unser antrag
für die österreichische staatsarchiv
damit
erzielt doch du zum top auch schon
ausmachen und hier haben wir
die selbstgemachten spätzle alter das
ich richtig krasser und echt gut aus
welche wir jetzt kaltes wasser geben zum
abstellen vielleicht kann es sein
vielleicht kann es sein das ist die
richtige frage bis wann muss ich nun
wissen wie der wagen schon mal unsere
fahrer ankommen gleich butter hinein
dann verbinden wir unsere frisch
gemachten durch geschwenkt und
käsespätzle mit dem kessel abtropfen
lassen und
[Musik]
kann zwischen alter was das in einem
auslösen kann natürlich ein kompetenter
gehen direkt mal ran mit ihnen im
schwarzen pfeffer greift uns jetzt schön
puristisch dazu gibt's noch mal richtig
wir nehmen unsere verschiedenen käse
bahn war das ist auch toll nach
gefühlten gar nicht genau ich hab' ich
habe gar nicht erst abgewogen wie viel
das sein könnte scheißegal oder absolut
scheißegal sobald der käse drin also die
mir ein bisschen runter mit der
temperatur für erst ein bisschen käse
die schmelzen bin schon werden kloster
string leute
muss so ein bisschen die walsh ist das
süße und magische mag ich hatte stand
teil der alles an so gut macht nämlich
schon oder der viele dass die geben wir
jetzt auf den teller muss muss ich immer
das sagen ich glaube frische petersilie
darüber und
[Musik]
wasserzeichen und was gesagt ist es zeit
für kas macht und einen weißen spritzer
danke
geister spritze in den kann ich mich auf
jeden fall auch wohl fühlen habe ich ja
schon mal festgestellt aber das sieht
doch wirklich traumhaft aus oder so
diese oberfläche und so diese ciesielski
weißt du was uns fehlt so eine geile
kleine gusseiserne empfangen das stimmt
allerdings verwehrt wir haben wird dann
werden wir komplett auf der hütte
angekommen es riecht sehr gut und ich
probiere die selbstgemachten kälte fest
das sind durch käsewürfel wird die sind
wichtig aber offen mit geiler art und
weise was eigentlich cool man kann das
über den käse die man verwendet
eigentlich perfekt dosieren dazu weiter
spritzig sie alex erfrischend leicht des
fleisches getränk zu dieser wucht von
einem abendessen nach diesem abendessen
werden schlafen legen können und ihr
seid deshalb gefragt in den kommentaren
abgestimmt welches land als nächstes
kulinarisch bereisen sollen stimmt in
den comics ab einfach durch einen like
und dank fürs zu sehen bis zum nächsten
video etwas ausprobieren und gut